bonjour à vous merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur arte france alors est ce que
l'on est ce que londres a réellement
violé cet accord du break site votre
question suppose que une violation est
établie ce qui à mon sens n'est pas
exactement le cas ce que dit l'autre et
qu' il y a des problèmes techniques qui
doivent être résolus c'est comme si vous
installez une nouvelle machine et que ne
marche pas parce qu'elle n'est pas
branché au bon endroit où il ya une ou
deux pièces qui manquent
ce qu'il faut faire ce rectifier ces
difficultés techniques dès que possible
et c'est ça le la nature de la situation
ici ce n'est pas une situation où il ya
une volonté de ne pas respecter l'accord
est donc je pense qu'il faut recadrer le
débat en ces termes je pense que c'est
une erreur de faire monter la
température en menant son ou en en
engageant des des actions en justice
bien entendu il faut que les accords
soient respectés que je suis est un
prospect sa part ça d'avoir deux soirs
mais en même temps il faut regarder et
écouter sur le terrain qui peuvent
exister et qui ne sont pas de totti qui
n'indiquent pas du tout le monde de
bonne foi alors les petits réglages
techniques auxquelles vous faisiez à
vision concerne justement les contrôles
douaniers
avec l irlande du nord de quoi
parle-t-on précisément je ne suis pas un
grand expert sur deux sur le sujet même
incompréhension et qu' il y à des
contrôles fait des cours de contrôles
sont prévus pour assurer que les
produits qui proviennent de l'angleterre
du pays de galles ou de vegas et qui
vont vers l'irlande du nord respecte des
règles de l'union européen
jusqu'il jusqu'au 1er janvier la loi me
faisait partie de l'union européenne
donc on supposerait que les mêmes normes
s'appliqueraient parce qu'il n'ait pas
eu le temps de créer des divergences
mais c'est ça le problème politique
générale et apparemment il n'y a pas
assez de personnes qui sont formés pour
faire les vérifications et donc il ya un
risque
s'agissant de produits alimentaires que
les livraisons soient sérieusement au
tableau il ya des pénuries dans des
magasins d'alimentation ce qui serait
quand même assez embêtant
et donc ce que disent les des autorités
britanniques sait qu il faut un peu plus
de temps que prévu pour régler ce
problème comme un témoin de signer avec
quelque chose qui est très important
politiquement il y a aussi des contrôles
qui sont prévues maintenant pour les
exportations de la france de l'allemagne
de la belgique vers novoa muni asi
contrôle qui doivent avoir lieu au
royaume uni son groupe portait aussi et
ça veut dire que les exportateurs
français allemand et cetera sont
épargnés exactement suivant la même
logique à savoir qu il faut plus de
temps à arriver dans un rapport d'après
six mois sur plusieurs creed ii de
produits
pour ben là c'est le temps nécessaire
pour mettre en chose de classe et non
pas le thomson c'est vrai que le royaume
uni avait annoncé un report de six mois
au début du mois de mars
les contrôles qui devraient tous
reprendre le 1er avril donc c'est
véritablement parce qu'on n'est pas en
mesure aujourd'hui de procéder à ces
contrôles n'ya pas les ressources
humaines c'est ce que vous nous dites
c'est la compression de la situation oui
je ne suis pas et les chantages -20%
vérité mais je crois que celle là la
réalité et il ya encore une fois pour le
tout et exportation vers vos droits et
muni ce serait les exportateurs français
séverin qui sera pénalisée si à une
application baptisée chance et je peux
dire été été effectuée par le premier
autorités donc ce que j'essaie de dire
c'est que il est important d'être
pragmatique et aussi d'entretenir un
minimum de bonne volonté pour construire
dans le temps cette nouvelle relation en
a on est au début des têtes d'une
situation nouvelle qui présentent quant
à eux de complexité il faut affectation
et avec une volonté de paris de régler
ce problème le trafic du possible bien
entendu mais au fur et mesure est censée
excité outre mesure penser que ce sera
réglé avant le délai imparti par l'union
européenne qui menace justement de
porter l affaire devant la cour de
justice de l'union européenne
je ne peux pas répondre à cette question
mais je suppose que c'est une menace qui
quitte rennes qui n'exclut pas l'idée de
négocier quand même pour trouver une
solution personnes et il a intérêt à
passer son temps à me traîner devant les
tribunaux ce serait vraiment un
un dernier recours c'est une tentative
d'exercer une pression sur le royaume
uni ont très bien se battre et que les
autorités avocats visiblement il
steen que c'est de bonne guerre encore
une fois je pense qu'il serait dommage
si il on résoudrait un engrenage un
négative où chacun lance des flèches à
un autre au lieu de travailler ensemble
sur le règlement de fait de ces pommes
avant de se quitter veulent thompson
hameau peut-être sur les chiffres du
commerce extérieur royaume uni en net
recul en janvier les exportations ont
plongé depuis de 19% penser qu'il ya des
regrets du côté outre-manche en par
rapport à la situation
non je ne pense qu'à le l'équipe en
place
absolument convaincu que le président
est globalement une bonne chose
et d'ailleurs les au tour du britannique
sa force de nous de conclure des accords
de libre commerce avec tes pays un peu
partout dans le monde ils ont fait un
moment l'intention d'exploiter les
possibilités de 2 devrait plus rapide
avec une agilité parce qu'ils sont c'est
un pays et par maintenant n'est pas
propre à l'espèce d'exploitation dont
vous parlez sont également liées à ses
difficultés initiales sommes qui seront
j'en suis certain régler assez assez
rapidement donc non je ne pense pas
hinault il n'est certainement pas de
regret en ce qui concerne ses goûts ses
pairs cette exportation je pense
qu'elles le seront au genou au passage
un merci beaucoup à vous pas le thomson
je rappelle que vous êtes à
vice-président de la section parisienne
du parti conservateur britannique
merci